well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they come in
in the next half hour then we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
consultant editor
of the daily mail andrew pearce and the
associate editor of the daily mirror
kevin mcguire great to see both hello
as ever then front pages before we get
your thoughts the guardian
leading with the prime minister sending
two royal navy ships to protect
jersey from a feared blockade by french
fishing
fishing vessels in an escalation of a
dispute over post-brexit access
to waters around the channel island the
daily mail pictures one of the vessels
being deployed
hms7 boris sends in the navy is also the
big splash there for
the metro also the lead for the
daily telegraph scotland's daily record
speaks to first minister nicholas
sturgeon who insists
she'd be prepared to work with the
labour party if the smp
can't secure an outright majority at
hollywood in tomorrow's elections
financial times has a story concerning
the hedge fund
i don't have pronounced at archigos
capital which is expected to declare
insolvency
and the star goes with donald trump
setting up his own website to keep
supporters
updated on his opinions show my lack of
knowledge there on ty but anyway let's
move on to
what is almost a clean sweep of the
newspapers on the
navy warships if you wanted to get the
front pages before an election
uh this is how to do it kevin isn't it
yeah
god really really cynical isn't it i
mean look it's uh it's made the sixth
tomorrow it's not april the first
but when france is uh threatening to cut
undersea electricity cables i'm not to
push you or two
warships on the uh on the surface would
do you know the male leads on it the
guardian
the the male is salivating over the
weapons on those
boats listing the uh the cannon and the
guns
that's right i can uh i can guarantee
they will not be fired now there are
french fisher
fishing boats threatening to blockade
the port
the truth is if you get 40 50 french
fishing
boats turning up there's very little
those two
uh warships can do this is just
electioneering by boris johnson who sold
the
fishing industry down the river and his
bad brexit deal
and now he wants to beat his chest wrap
himself in the flag
and pose as a defender of the fishing
industry
against the french it's all pretty
pathetic
andrew well you're not surprising i
don't agree with the word that kevin
mcguire says i don't at the best of
times but he's
excelled himself with the cant he's
speaking tonight
look the french have behaved
outrageously
sanctioned by a government minister
threatening to cut off electricity
supplies to jersey
in a dispute over fishing access now
i don't know who's right who's wrong
whether it's jersey or france but jersey
say
before the french had to show evidence
that these these
tr these trawlers have fished in jersey
waters these are small boats
they the jersey authorities say they've
not provided it
french france carrying on like they're
still in the eu
bullying and throwing their weight
around think they can bully little
jersey
good old boris johnson sending in the
royal navy i think people will be
cheering this
up and down the land i think it is
coincidence of course we've got
elections tomorrow
but also we know that this little
flotilla of french trawlers are on their
way because i think tomorrow
is the 200th anniversary of the death of
napoleon bonaparte and let's not forget
we saw him off too so we can see him off
again i think it's a
fantastic piece of gumbo diplomacy by
boris
fantastic labour labour party
eight yards out thank you right on the
eve of the election too what
the party
back against little bony and he's
marauding army on the concrete
we saw him off then we said we'll see
him off again we still have the armada
kevin don't forget to
yeah you love the prussians and now now
the germans coming to
standing up for british interest that's
our prime minister
this is utterly ludicrous
it's quite easy to condemn the french
government's threats and they deserve to
be calm down but it needs somebody to
say let's all
calm down and be a bit sensible let's
not be scenting
warships which of course johnson does
and andrew
tory boy there said well it's no
coincidence on the eve of the election
we know what it is it's just a cynical
political ploy by a charlatan
in downing street that's what it is
a charlatan in downing street who
according to the polls is going to get a
lot more votes
than the charleston running the labour
party at the moment secure who
uh and uh and you know jersey is a very
small island and it needs someone to
stand up for it and boris is doing just
that
he's going to be a good prime minister
after talking to the first minister of
jersey
so jersey wanted the help has he has he
got donors living in jersey
you know for the tax advantages before
he's slipping money for wallpaper and uh
perks he likes foreign good try kevin
it's certainly united the newspapers
though hasn't it uh making the front of
the mail
and the guardian and as i said most of
the other newspapers
um daily mail front page if we just go
back to that as we head towards our
election coverage
uh boris sends gun boats into jersey and
then down the bottom if we lose that
uh strap tori's election day jabs
booster so you're laying it on thick for
the uh
for anybody who's thinking of voting
tory aren't you but let's go to the
election then last push
for many of the newspapers this is
fascinating isn't it
um kevin to you first of all um who's
quaking in their boots over this
enormous electoral test um secure
stamber the pressure is on surely
yeah no i i think it is uh let the
conservative party have got uh
a big pole lead from a vaccine bounce
they were beginning to fall behind
in some polls but before before
christmas starman was right
rating better than johnson the nhs mass
vaccination program has been a huge
success and the government will get
some credit for that just as it deserves
much blame for 127 7 thousand deaths and
economic damage which were both uh
inflicted much heavier than uh would
have needed to to to be so no it's it's
it's kierstarma the pressure is on in
the heart of the pool by election
what happens in the west midlands and
tees valley uh
mayoral battles both conservative needs
to be winning those back
what happens in some of those north of
england labor seats the red wall seat
does he make gains or will labor be
losing councillors and councils
in wales mark drake for the first
minister of labor there is widely
praised uh for his handing of the the
pandemic but what happens to labour
can it uh can it stay in power and if it
stays in power which is its majority
then you go to scotland which is
probably constantly
certainly constitutionally the most
important election
of all does the snp get a majority
and then can labour pip the
conservatives to second
place that's that's what these elections
are is essentially about
yeah um andrew your take on this um
clearly
uh boris johnson has made a few visits
to hartlepool which is the by-election
which is the first result we're going to
get
quite a drawn-out results process
certainly as we head into the weekend
yeah i mean we're going to have to wait
a long time i don't think we're going to
get the london result which we all know
is uh it's
sadika wins by a mile anyway till sunday
but um kevin says that boris johnson's
had a vaccine bounce yes of course he
has
he's also benefited from the fact that
the labour campaign is utterly vacuous
uh they've had very little to say we
just heard kirsten muttering the same
old mantra tori sleeves stories please i
think he needs to remember
but most voters under the age of 50
don't remember a single thing
about john made his government and how
it was beset with fleas
i think he's been banging up the wrong
tree the whole way through this election
campaign he should have found something
positive to talk about
instead he's just um churned out the
same old thing and i think it hasn't cut
through very well for him
this is a huge disaster of him if he
loses heart default because even jeremy
corbyn
who led labour to their worst election
defeat since 1935
managed to hold on to hartley ball not
once but twice and he won nine out of
ten by elections
this would only be the third or fourth
time a government has
won a seat from an opposition party in a
by-election if indeed victories
win hartlepool which would be a measure
of kirsten's failure
i mean this is this is fascination let's
go to the daily record um showing that
only because
uh it's talking about the s p working
with labor certainly north of the border
labor have had a torrid decade haven't
they
you start losing scotland you start
losing
your heartlands in the north of england
does this begin to be
existential for the labour party you
can't blame corbyn anymore because he's
not there
so what what does labour do about it if
they ever want to win a general election
after
these local elections obviously yeah you
know anna nationally across
uh across great britain the labor votes
been in decline
since uh 1997 and the the high point
that huge tony blair majority is a very
low turnout
in 2001 then in 2005
lost about half the seats then you go
back
uh actually the the labor vote in 2010
and in 2015
were lower as a proportion of the
electorate than in 2019 under corbyn
when got the worst
westminster result in terms of seats
since 1935 so
labor's in long-term uh long-term
decline and somehow has to
has to arrest him one way you can say
stalin was never going to change that
very quickly and
what's happened with the pandemic
initially because of all the mistakes on
care homes ppe
number of people dying dithering on
lockdown he managed to
be the serious man in serious times and
work that to his advantage and people
were turning against johnson but then
the vaccines come along
and it seems to have inoculated labor
against uh
against success and i mean he's right in
one way
andrew about the pool it would be it
would be only the fourth
time since the second world war that a
governing party has taken a seat
from the opposition uh there has been a
tory mp
in in that seat before the heart of the
pools it was it was 1959
uh 64. but labor labor
should be increasingly majority in a
seat like that and i know
i know the pandemic has changed politics
but you should be making progress if
you're the labor leader
so it's not the end he's not going to be
there'll be calls upon from the left for
him to go and in fact the seat was only
held in 2019 because the brexit party
got 10 and a half thousand votes if they
haven't got those votes
labour would have lost it then and those
who say well
look corbin held er heart the pool no no
you uh you should well corbin also
saw boris johnson they don't accept
responsibility for that so i'm not sure
you can just say
it's it's as simple as colton held it in
2017 2019
starmer loses it in 2021 if he does
then that that means he's is much so
much worse it's finished it's a
what a work in progress they would say
but he's he's got a
big mountain to climb as well as labour
in in general has a big
number and can i just say one other
thing on hartley paul i don't know
what idiot decided that the labour
candidate in hartlepool
should be not just a remainer but a
fanatical pro eu supporter
when hartlepool voted by 70 to leave the
european union
and he was kicked out by the voters of
stockton south this guy
two years ago for the same reason in my
view he was a
fanatical remain remainer in a leave
constituency so what possessed them
to put that guy in that seat it's been a
terrible terrible area of judgment and
one for which i think his dharma has
must take
quite a lot of responsibility well we
find out but he is like he is a local gp
who's been on the covered front line for
a year
so i i don't think you should be just
going so dismissive
of him as a person uh you know he has
been busy saving
lives and deserves some great for that
yeah well lots and lots of coverage
and for all of us i think over the
coming days it's fascinating contests
didn't even get to talk about scotland
properly perhaps we'll do that in the
next time we uh
we see you but back for more in just a
moment we'll see you um after the break
and coming up the g7 meetings in london
disrupted
by positive covert tests talk about that
in just a moment
i'm alex crawford and i'm sky's special
correspondent based in istanbul
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do
they fear they'll be killed
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day
can't access those and knees you can see
the depth of water if you have a look in
front of us there are people wading
through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment i don't like the
chinese government it's true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber bullets
see fires all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around
31 000 football pitches
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok
[Music]
well welcome back to watching the press
preview with me now andrew pearce and
kevin mcguire welcome back to both of
you
um andrew let's go to the metro shall we
everyone's been watching in absolute
horror what's been happening
in india um but you bring a delegation
over here and and look what happens
yeah and we could have worked it out
couldn't we uh india's got the worst
covered infection rate anywhere in the
world and it's probably much worse
actually than the true figures than the
figures are showing so
two members of the delegation have um
been confirmed as having covered
uh it means the home secretary half the
british delegation are now being checked
we'll probably have to go into isolation
the question is why did we feel the need
to bring them in why could we have
talked to their the indian delegation on
zoo
partly because we just struck a mini
trade deal with india so i suppose we
wanted to
put some um uh bunting on that deal but
my question is why are we allowing any
flights in from india
at all i'd have banned them uh just for
a few weeks
about 10 or 11 countries have already
done so including saudi arabia and new
zealand
i think when i think it's madness yeah i
think most people thought they had been
banned given it's on the red list but um
it doesn't work like that does it it
just means you have to go to hotel
quarantine but there we are
um
for diplomats but there is now a big
question what you do about the g7 the
world leaders biden
macron merkel all others uh coming to
the
judiciary of the uk they're going to
call this carpus bay in
cornwall uh next month are you still are
you still going to have such movement
will they actually
want to come when it could be spreading
the virus
and the wh making quite clear today that
the priority must be to get nations like
india vaccinated
instead here we're talking about a third
booster vaccine for
for some adults in the population of the
uk
uh with all this money now being thrown
at variance of concern as well to work
out what the vaccine no doubt should be
what's what's the latest from the
guardian kevin
it's it's a small trial uh that's shown
that you tweet you
tweak uh the vaccines and they're very
successful
against the south african and brazilian
variants for
for example and it's why when you get
the booster if it won't be the same as
your
your first two jobs but it will protect
you further and it is
in the uk a lot of the world in the usa
um biden's first hundred days those
million jobs given so
western wealthy economies once they get
going can be really successful at this
because
we begin to protect ourselves but we're
never gonna protect it
as long as countries like uh india are
struggling to get enough vaccine
in into arms and there's not just a
moral case for help and there's also a
self-interest
um you've got 10 seconds on michelle
barnier's diaries
andrew yeah he's the old boy from the eu
was their chief negotiator on brexit and
he's described boris johnson he thought
boris johnson had a madman strategy
in the brexit talks which he thought
caused turmoil well
madmen strategy it may have been but it
worked because he got a brexit deal
against all the odds and if we would if
teresa may was still prime minister
we'd still be waiting yeah he sold the
fishing industry down the river he's got
a border
you've got huge guns uh people complain
it's marvelous
brexit's going very well kevin thank you
brexit's going very very well
very happy with it we haven't got time
to open that again uh we'll see
half eleven thank you